hey this is presh tallwalker
construct a semi-circle with center o
label one of its endpoints as a
and then construct a perpendicular ob
to ao
now connect a and b together
and let its midpoint be point d
from there let's construct a semi-circle
centered at point d
now consider
the area
between a e b f
and the triangle [ __ ]
what is the ratio between the yellow
area aevf and the blue triangle [ __ ]
this is a famous historical problem
aebf is called a loon deriving from the
latin word luna for moon
this is credited to hippocrates of kaios
who solved this in ancient times nearly
a hundred years before euclid
now i should mention this is not the
same hippocrates of course who's the
doctor of hippocratic oath fame
so you might think this is a very basic
geometric problem
but remember this was even before euclid
wrote the elements
this is said to be the first precise
mathematical calculation of an area
between curved lines
this is even before the familiar formula
for the area of a circle
so
hippocrates use very basic principles
this was solved using the pythagorean
theorem
and the second fact that the area of a
circle is proportional to its diameter
squared
using just these principles can you
solve for the ratio between the yellow
loon and the blue triangle
i want to thank sahil day and byron from
melbourne who suggested this problem can
you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
historical solution
first let's label the diameter of the
circle as ac
since [ __ ] is an isosceles right triangle
a b is equal to ao times the square root
of 2 by the pythagorean theorem
we can then deduce that the diameter ac
which is equal to 2 times the radius ao
is equal to a b times the square root of
2.
because a circle's area is proportional
to its diameter squared
semicircle abc has two times the area as
semi-circle aeb
consequently half of semicircle abc
which is the quarter circle afboa
has the same area as the semicircle aeb
in other words
the area of this quarter circle
is exactly equal to the area of this
semi-circle
and now we've pretty much solved it
here comes the magical step the loon aeb
f and the triangle [ __ ] are both found by
subtracting the same area
afba
from shapes that have equal area the
semicircle aeb and the quarter circle
afboa
thus the loon and the triangle are found
by subtracting the same area from shapes
of equal area
therefore their areas are equal
you can also write this out
algebraically
and you will note that these two shapes
have the same area and you're
subtracting the same area from each of
them
therefore the two areas are equal
so i assume you'll be able to figure
this out because it's a basic
geometrical problem
but it should remind you some of these
problems that we find very basic and
routine today
were challenging thousands of years ago
so i hope this inspires you to solve a
problem today
with students thousands of years from
now will learn in grade school
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can catch
me on social media either at mind your
decisions or at preshtalwalker